Elizabeth is with us in Oregon hi
Elizabeth welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show thanks I'm excited to get to advise
so I have a brother who I'm trying to
help through his financial situation we
just gifted him SPU for Christmas but I
don't think he started yet so the
details are he makes anywhere between 51
and 61 a year he has about 21 thousand
dollars in debts between a car loan and
a family loan and he has decided to well
he's on the sex offenders list so his
lease is up in June and they can't find
anywhere to rent and so he's worried
that his wife and their you know who
will be two month old baby will be
homeless come then unless he snatched
this grand scheme he took out a thousand
dollar loan from his 401k I already
tried to talk him out of it but it's
done I guess and then he has these
supposed insider information that he's
going to invest and then grow it
supposedly very quickly into a down
payment for a house I don't like my
husband and I've been following it for
years I've tried talking to him but I
don't know how to get across to him that
this is not the best course of action
but on the other hand I'm not really
sure what to advise so I'm hoping to get
your help I have been desperate a time
or two in my life
and that is when I'm the dumbest mm-hmm
desperate usually equals stupid and
that's what he is yeah he feels trapped
he's worried about his baby and his wife
and he just visited the land of stupid
everything you're telling me is stupid
is it yes but I don't know what to do
yeah I know I understand but the reason
is and I think the only place you could
start with is just to empathize with the
fear that he has
and just say I understand you're scared
and usually people when they make their
biggest financial mistakes or when
they're scared mm-hmm it's when they go
to the payday lender its when they fall
forget rich quick schemes he's going to
lose this thousand dollars and then he's
still gonna have a housing problem yeah
and I'm gonna look at him and tell him
that I mean it doesn't sound like he's
listening to you much though this is all
new him try he's he is
he said when we gave him s to you that
he's really excited about it and he
really wants to get his life on track
and then income until today and I mean I
get scared scared he gets crazy yeah
yeah fear fear is is a it pretty much
ensures you're about to do something
stupid with money you know when I hear
people say stuff like I was forced to
buy a car that's why I have a 38%
interest rate that's somebody that felt
trapped and scared right yeah and that's
what he's doing right now when you fall
for get-rich-quick when you fall for
scams
it's either greed or fear and in his
case it's fear mm-hmm and so what I
would do is sit down with him and his
wife if you can you and your husband and
say guys you're getting ready to make a
huge mistake you've already made one
you're getting ready to make another and
it's all based on fear we've got to
solve your housing problem without you
freaking out and you're going to face
this for a while with with being on the
sex offenders list and you've got to you
know find housing that is suitable that
meets his guidelines are there laws I
assume that he can't be but so close to
a school or whatever right yes there's a
very small distance so his his rules are
pretty lenient compared to some others
yeah all right so the only problem is is
if it comes up on a background check in
a landlord freaks out yes yes that's
what it is so the way you the way you
circumvent that is you get to know the
landlord mm-hmm and you say listen I got
to tell you you're going to find this it
was a minor event yours
go or whatever the story is I don't know
what story is and you know obviously I'm
a young man with a house with a family
and a child and I'm not gonna be someone
that's going to be a problem for you in
any way and you just you have a normal
human being that's a landlord that looks
at him and walks past that and there's
lots of people that will do that
I would not I'm a landlord and I would
not return down someone exclusively on
that reason now I would want to know
more I want to know who I'm putting in
my house I don't want some freak in
there right yeah but but I want to know
what so I know what the story is let me
think about it if you're the landlord
but but a reason if there's a reasonable
story here and I'm looking at a young
man who's scared to death with a wife
and child who's straightening his life
out after some kind of a thing happened
X number of time ago lots of people
believe in given that somebody a second
chance if you got a reasonable narrative
around it but are you going to go into
just any old apartment and slap down a
deposit no they're probably not going to
rent to it mm-hmm
they don't because they just got you
know they just they throw the baby out
with the bathwater on everything they're
doing they also won't rent to me because
I don't have a credit score so you know
he's in good company in that regard so
the product the thing is you got to
solve his problem
so the quits being stupid cuz he's gonna
lose his money he's gonna he's gonna
make some other mistakes it's kind of
scared out of his mind
yeah and on top of that he faces
continuous shaming for this label mm-hmm
and all of this you know it just boat
does not bode well for anything except
desperate and every time I get desperate
my stupid meter just goes off I do some
of the dumbest things in my life ever
when I was scared and desperate cuz you
can justify and rationalize anything in
that situation you know I can't let my
child be homeless you know that that in
the name of that you can do almost
anything
that's dumb right yeah and so you get
all this melodrama going around the
desperation and we dramatize everything
and your brain quits working and that's
what's going on he's thrashing so you
got a you got a throw cold water and
calm him down sit down with his spouse
help them develop a new plan that does
not involve stupid and then I don't feel
trapped and they don't feel scared and
you can coach them through that nothing
in your area they are not where you live
a couple states away okay you're gonna
be doing this by FaceTime then but yeah
yeah but just the same what I just told
you is exactly true now how long ago was
the charge on him uh two years ago I
believe okay all right so is there a
story that can be told that is
reasonable that is that shows this in
the rearview mirror there definitely is
okay then tell that to regular people
who are landlords and find someone who
will have mercy on a young couple with a
baby that needs a house mm-hmm
that kind okay that's simple and you
know it's kind of like this okay who
would rent to somebody that just filed
bankruptcy I would because they can't
file bankruptcy again for one thing okay
so it makes them a great risk no as a
landlord but secondly I want to hear the
story did you learn something from this
or are you still doing the crap that
caused you to be bankrupt and if I can't
get the story and I can see what's going
on they actually might be somebody
that's actually learned their lesson
versus somebody it's not bankrupt as
deeply in debt and can't pay their bills
right right but an apartment complex
can't think like that they're not
allowed to think we have to do what
somebody in Atlanta or Chicago in the
Home Office told them they had to do
mm-hmm
but if you just get the little old lady
in a little man that have a little ol
place to rent over here like me you know
you can talk that that's all but all of
this comes down to desperation do you
agree yes they do yeah and then he can
calm down and he can go through FPU and
he can start stabilizing his life but
he's thrashing around fear-based and a
hundred percent of time that's gonna
bring damage hunt it's like input
it's like impulse impulse always
brings damage anytime I impulse
something I it's it's my highest
likelihood of making a bad purchase it's
my highest likelihood of paying too much
it's my highest likelihood of buying
something I don't need it's my highest
likelihood of buying something that that
I regret buying later he who is
impulsive exalts folly the proverb says
folly is the verb of a fool in action
it's what I'm talking about